anger and disappointment outside the  Sanford courtroom after the verdict was  announced I think it's outrageous  drinkin bourbon is a headed murder we  racially profile Trayvon he started and  murdered her jurors had a different  point of view they said George Zimmerman  had acted within the law when he shot  Trayvon Martin in February last year  Florida has a stand-your-ground law  which allows anyone to use force if they  fear for their lives obviously we are  ecstatic with the results George  Zimmerman was never guilty of anything  except protecting himself in  self-defense do you think lawyers for  the dead man's family says mmm can't  have acted in self-defense since the  teenager was unarmed Carl America has to  dig deep in their heart to try to find  out how we as a society can learn from  this tragedy the case prompted a  national debate in the u.s. about race  relations Zimmerman is now a free man  but that discussion is certain to  continue  you